okay I got my intro already lined up for
this one all right well we
are live I believe are we live right now
I believe we are live right
now the weekly poll I am comic story and
that is TV little house that is marel
explain that is Comics reviews Gwen
Stacy is a spider person it's amazing
this week future end is horrendous this
week and on top of that we
are and Dave's not wearing any
pants no no
stanle ifus
everybody I I need a new one every week
what do you want from me that's
fair listen that's how it goes um yeah
hey
here what up hey I believe we're live
hey wait all of that we weren't even
live I mean no we're live man we're live
I'm telling you we're live right now I'm
so video
here but yeah so what are are we
discussing today guys uh well talking
about the Punisher is one thing like I
wanted to talk about the Punisher but
people I think also wanted to see us
talk about um Old Man Wolverine or Old
Man Logan robotic Supergirl yeah it
makes no
sense wait wasn't she gonna be a red
lantern it's in the future it's a
robot so she's a red lantern robot no no
no she got rid of that ring and
apparently immediately became a robot
yeah well they're turning everybody
legit
seems
legit yeah looks
legit um all right soad us Rob lead us I
I I am I am I am leading I am leading
the podcast I'm talking discuss the fact
that we are all going to New York Comic
people are like the video like the the
videoos Frozen I'm like if that [__]
ain't Frozen that's just fine like it's
sh's working for me we should all talk
in accents like this today hello hello
everyone welcome to the weekly pool
welcome to the weekly look my what is
this what has happened oh God I'm taking
crazy pills we took a week off and we're
all
Deadpool yeah YouTube uh YouTube
hiccuped it looks like I don't know
maybe it's maybe it's part of the whole
YouTube twitch conversion I think I
misspelled hicup I don't know but hello
everyone welcome to officially starting
the doing again again yeah no I mean
it's it was stre it's been streaming the
whole time like it's been fine the whole
time again why you got to interrupt me
yo never not been stream G welcome to
the weekly poll where this week Futures
End sucks spider person is awen Stacy
Miles Morales has joined the all new
X-Men I don't even know what's going on
in Team Titans Star-Lord had an issue
last week this is a really crazy looking
cover welcome to the weekly po I'm comic
story and that is s from P little that
is Rob from Marvel explain and that is
Dave from comic viws and I don't need to
breathe I'm
Benny Benny does not breathe
we're doing this weird voice I love I
love doing this weird voice I love
talking this day long I'm gonna twe this
out oh man all right so so uh so the
death all right so the death of wolver
rain all right like obviously I think it
goes without that saying like it's a
huge hit like people are pretty psyched
about wolver finally dying which is
about time like he's needed to be dead
like he's done a million times but now
apparently they're just gonna say he
stays dead the next X-Men movie I hope
he does I mean like everybody keeps
saying that but I'm like why like who
cares if Wolverine's dead or not like
number one he'll be back and number two
like Wolverine's one of the few
unkillable characters that's kind of
like what made him into an interesting
character which is also by the way why
Death of Wolverine is so interesting
because like he's usually so unkillable
so now he is killable and that's making
him interesting so you know that's kind
of neat also the art like still not
interesting I will say death The
Wolverine is a great book I'm liking it
so far but it has not like put Wolverine
into my world I'm like I'm gonna go buy
a bunch of Wolverine books oh yeah
they're gonna be cool oh no buying more
Wolverine BS I I'm like oh look he's the
same Wolverine but now he gets hurt and
oh no he should be using his claws so
wink um I will tell you like
I that's the sound of CLA man it's like
like I I saw that oh how was it go s
yeah Snick that's what it is that's
Snick what is s sounds like sck
Nickelodeon Nick Nick yeah dude sick man
um I actually got on I got on Google one
day because I was looking up like
Wolverine quotes and that was like face
I asked like best Wolverine quotes and
like it was this Comic Vine thread and
it was like guys list your best
Wolverine quotes like the number one
quote was like
snicked yeah that's it that's not even
him though that's the sound of Cl I know
the sound of his
claws I comments here comment STV
anderon says welcome back I had to
settle for the tweakly poll last week a
bunch of meth heads in Walmart parking
lot discussing
comic to the twe
po me on
caffeine po I traveled five years into
the future all right all right let's go
ahead say now like STV Ander moon is
like the superhero of the podcast that's
it and we will awesome you guys next
week thank for us
everybody oh man this success another
Triumph everybody um all right so I I
will say this like the death of wolver
rain is decent like it's it's decent
enough I'm just looking forward to
wolver rain being gone but I will say
that I'm I'm with Benny on this one like
I don't look at the death of Wolverine
and I'm like oh my God what an amazing
Story the last great story involving
involving like Wolverine was Old Man
Logan and that was it like I loved Old
Man Logan that was cool it was cool I I
think that last best Wolverine story was
Wolverine by
Claremont personally I think the best
Wolverine story was Wolverine Origins
and that was it when we found out his
past and they remove origin yeah when
they removed the Mystique of what
wolverine is and you're like oh he's
just an experiment who forgot everything
yeah
great the the the Jenkins cubert origin
book is solid that is a fantastic book
and I love the origin of it which was
just like
uh you know if you guys don't know the
X-Men movie was about to be made yeah
and Marvel was like they're going to do
the origin in the movie we should do the
origin first because we care like the
the the the the Marvel people the X-Men
people The Wolverine people they were
all like we don't want to tell the
origin of Wolverine we like having it
kind of be this mystery how old is
Wolverine we don't know like how long
has he been around who knows like we
don't know his parents or anything like
that we don't know what's going on with
Wolverine we like can't of keep that as
like one of the few Mysteries of the
Marvel Universe but the movie's going to
do it anyway because they don't give a
[__] about what we're doing right so we
might as well tell it as best we can and
I think they really succeeded especially
when they were trying to pull his [__]
together to do it like oh crap we need
we need Paul Jenkins and one of the
certs I don't care who and just but
that's that's what I say like like a lot
of people are like they raise raise an
eyebrow and they're a little skeptical
when I say like if you want to read
anything good in Marvel go read Paul
Jenkins and then they're just kind of
like I he's all right and I'm like no
Paul Jenkins is pretty damn good when it
comes to writing I I think the problem
with Wolverine was that what before we
had the origin you could make up any
story 1600 and Wolverine was just set
him in it just put him in it and
everyone was like oh my God Wolverine
was alive in the 1600s he was a milkmade
what yeah they could have they could
have easily made it so that like like
they throw Captain America back into
like the Paleozoic Era and Wolverine's
like a caveman oh what's going on in
Wolverine I'm the first m this guy this
guy um at least six people he says that
um the best Wolverine story was Hulk 181
then it was
downhill the same problem they had with
Weapon X weapon x was a great mysterious
thing that they could keep adding to
without a problem once we found out the
story of weapon x it was like now
anytime you throw something in there it
doesn't make sense we had plus we had
Roman or whatever his name is like like
the whole Roman guy Roman that's stupid
like I made the video for Weapon X and a
bunch of people like well you didn't
explain Ro Mist whatever I'm like he
came out in 2010 he's not in the story
that's not part of the story The the
story of weapon x is just that cool
picture of Wolverine with the VR helmet
and all like the tombs on his body
that's all anyone thinks of when they
think of weapon x and it's like yeah
that's awesome it's a badass I mean like
like in the Age of Apocalypse like wol
rain was called Weapon X like that was
his
name I think uh and and Jean Gray's
nickname or her her code name was
Phoenix which is like finally she said
no no code name for the last 30 years
and finally she had red well she was
also Marvel girl yeah that's true I
loved um I remember in the in the 90s I
think Bishop refers to Jean Gray at some
point as Phoenix he's just like okay
Phoenix let's do this and that was the
first time I'd ever seen anyone casually
call her that as like a code name and I
was like yeah that makes sense that's
really cool that and then they never did
it again I'm like that was the event
directly after the Phoenix force was um
or the X-Men were able to defeat the uh
Imperial Guard yes during the trial of
the Phoenix force or the trial of Jean
Gray that was God that was such a good
story right I I miss Chris Claremont
X-Men so much I mean like he could just
do it like I don't know why he's not
still working on X-Men because he
doesn't need to I mean if I were him I
just i' I just I'd take X-Men's going
downhill I've got uncanny here somewhere
it sucks man like X-Men sucks all new
X-Men like you've got like Cyclops who's
like I'm the new Magneto
Cyclops versus Zombie Cyclops yeah it
sucks man I mean okay this is the issue
I'm not even kidding but the the whole
thing Wolverine it's time to kill him
because they've killed all of his
Mystique Wolverine has now become a
character that we're not wondering
anything about and he's just become a
character who he shows he's the one that
killed Hank Pim he's the one that was
going to kill hope he he's just that guy
that shows up all the time now with no
real reason or story or nothing he's
just there well like they've already
killed everyone else they might as well
kill Wolverine
2o Spider-Man has literally died twice
Captain America's been dead two or three
times no Spider-Man was Spider-Man has
technically not been killed he was he's
been brought back to life so he was
never dead and the first no he was dead
there was there's two stories I'm just
no actually in Spiderman number 32 I
don't remember actually what number it
was but it was right it was during The
Infinity Gauntlet story arc there was
actually like a kind of tie-in where
Spider-Man gets covered in free on
and he dies and he goes before Thanos
and death and then he fights Thanos and
then like death feels bad for him and
lets him
survive he's gonna die by Mor Lon again
see that that's see this this is this is
what I'm talking about man we talked
about this before we started the podcast
guys and for those of you who were
sending me a message on YouTube because
there were so many of you who were like
why didn't you talk about [__] in the
totems because it's
stupid I mean happened it's now part gon
has attacked twice he's going to be back
in this stupid edge of spider or
spiderverse story that's three epic
tales with more lo don't worry guys
don't worry guys comic story will cover
that well you have fun you have fun
talking about how Rhino wants to kill
Spider-Man because rhinos hate spiders
so no that's not what it is that's
exactly what it is that's exactly how it
explain it's that there there's it's
that there are all these animalistic
totems and they're all naturally
attracted to each other so like there's
the Scorpion and the Rhino and the the
like the Hunter and like the whatever
the hell vulture you know you got all
these different animal totems and
Spider-Man's one of them and like that
like whatever like and it also that that
story The Book of Ezekiel allowed you to
go like if you don't believe in this
stuff like you don't have to like it's
doesn't like I think that's what
happened but like if you want to believe
that like a radioactive spider bit you
and gave you spider powers and like
crazy people dressed like animals like
that's fine too I'm like yeah I'll take
that thank you well we know that's true
like you know how we know that's true
because we have silk yeah we have silk
and and the alternate timeline um I
believe it's uh this one Stacy yeah we
have Gwen Stacy I don't know yeah I
really want to know that story I don't
care what you say s I really want to
know why Gwen Stacy first off first Gwen
Stacy Spider-Man in that timeline right
but not only that but she's Spider-Man
with a hoodie how does that help with
the peripherals you know like hoodie it
just looks cool it's literally just it's
good design like it's a bad practical
design but it's a great like that's like
90% of the women's costumes in comic
books anyway I'm gonna put bandages over
my nipples and that's gonna hold well
Frank Miller's writing them sure but
like man can we talk really quick about
that book I don't know if anybody's SE
even if you've just seen the art for
edge of spiderverse number two with the
Gwen Stacy Spiderwoman book I just read
it uh yesterday and it is so good I
haven't read I'm not I'm not that big of
a I'm not I'm I know you're not really
into the the man in blue and red but
like well I'm I'm not that big on and
plus it's also like he's not big on
anything after the90s I'm not big on
them bringing like Gwen Stacy back to
the to the main Universe because GW
Stacy dying was extremely important for
Peter Parker to like really step into
the I know it's not the same one but
it's no this is
symbolically here's my theory real quick
he speaking about this and then not the
same one that is gonna be the okay so
they're gonna get rid of Wolverine right
we're killing off Wolverine which is the
whole point of this beginning of this
discussion we're killing off Wolverine
my theory is because Marvel's like we
are never bringing up back we're never
bringing them back yeah at the end of
this whole eight month because now we
have eight months till the Avengers End
of Time happens or something timeline's
gonna break everything's GNA snap a
different Wolverine will come out of a
different timeline and that'll be their
way to bring him back inhuman Wolverine
will come out of a different timeline oh
God timeline be like I'm an inhuman I
work at black all of the New Mutants
that were brought back in AVX were
actually
Inhumans and then they're going to kill
off the rest of the mutants I like make
them Inhumans so that they can use all
of the X-Men in the Marvel movies if
Marvel if Marvel does that you know what
I'm going to do Marvel does that if
Marvel does that I'm shutting my channel
down I'm explaining Mar last last video
the last video will be Rob setting
himself on fire in the parking lot
no DC explain and then he can yeah
Robert
what one thing though with this though
Rob and I had Rob had a theory I think
it was Rob that you came up with it that
the DC Universe is entirely in Batman's
head yes no no no it's in Superman's
head no no it was in Batman's because
it's the only reason why a guy like
Batman would be better than Superman oh
okay yeah maybe
that's yeah so it's like the uh crap
what is
that so here's my prediction for what
happens if my prediction comes true with
Rob Rob will pick up his first DC
Book I'm telling he'll Become dc
explained he already came to me and said
I want to explain Superman and I said go
for it that is lots of history and then
Rob came back a day later and said you
are so right I'm not doing
that yeah the history is It's Gonna Take
Me of Superman yeah I I okay so history
of super here how this start all right
so let me let me explain this
because he's like would you be upset if
I did Super and I'm like go for it no
here okay I want to do the history of
hold on let me let me let me explain let
me explain you can't just go and do the
the origin of of Superman and Benny you
need to you need to fix your your
microphone because your camera and your
microphone's all messed up but yeah um
your internet connection's so here's
here here's how this all happened all
right so I was sitting here and I was
thinking I wonder how people would react
if I just did like a Superman explained
on on my Marvel
just to see you know if I could do like
a Superman explain and I think people
would be they'd be down be like I think
April one you should try that well April
one I think you should do a totally
different intro it should be blue hold
that up I gotta jump in and out you're
probably need to fix sound okay oh okay
um yeah you should do you should do a
totally new intro with like different
music and a different color and like
like you've been doing it it's still
shitty I don't know what happened it's
whatever but it's better now yeah okay
but um so the the way this whole thing
started I was sitting here I was like I
wonder if I could do do Superman so I
was experimenting with it for a while
and then Benny got online and I was like
hey man like let me let me ask you a
question he says okay so I hit him up on
I called him on Skype and I was like I'm
thinking about doing like like a
unexplained on Superman and he was like
what I was like like Superman and he's
like do you have any idea how massive
Superman's history is yeah I was like
that bad like yeah I I didn't think it
was that bad so
like my exact wording was
I I remember my exact wording was he's
the first superhero Rob yeah try it he
is he is yeah he's he's the archetype
for superheroes and so like yeah like I
went on Wikipedia like I was like
whatever I don't know anything about
Superman so I got on Wikipedia like
that's the longest history I've ever
seen for a character anything about
Superman I know I know Superman can like
go faster than a speeding bullet and
he's more powerful than locomotive and
he can leap tall buildings in single
bound they know Superman that's all
that's all I know about Superman that's
it that's why when he asked he's like
would you be offended if I did Superman
I'm like go for it man I don't think
I'll ever do that that be like saying
like would you be offended if I did a
trip to the zoo like yeah it has no
bearing on what I'm doing I had no idea
how like woefully unprepared I was to do
an explain because I was I was looking
through that and it was I was like oh my
God like this would have to be like a
month like a monthlong Endeavor
explaining
Superman you could a week you could do
just a week of the death of
Superman I could I could I was I was
thinking about that I was like I'm not
explaining Superman no you could
actually my hand around the Omnibus yeah
yeah it's like it's like 1,500 pages I
can barely wrap my fingers around it wow
you that's what said you should do pre
crisis Superman crisis Superman post
crisis Superman new 50 you break it up
oh you also need to at some point do
Grant Morrison I can sing Dark Side to
death Superman I'm not doing I am not
doing American Idol Superman that's not
happening you should also do Allstar
Superman because it's a totally
different but it's also like a hot like
that's the way to that's the way to book
end it then there's Earth one Earth One
Superman That's Another Universe yeah
Superman is so horrible oh my God you're
you're such a purist s you are was good
I like one Superman is so lousy like it
is then there's also all the all the
else worlds what about all those oh my
God what about Red Sun Superman where
he's Russian Union Jack Superman Union
Jack Superman I am not explaining
Superman Nightmare Superman screw this
man I'll do back you could do the
Superman where Kalel lands in Gotham
City and a kindly couple named the
Waynes raise him yeah bad all right so
so Rob if you want to do bad one he
becomes a Green Lantern you can do that
Superman y you could do you could do
Frank Miller's Superman you could do the
in
continuity you could do new 52 Batman
you can do you can do uh like the Tim
sale Universe Batman we're gonna do
Batman too you can do Allstar Batman
that painted an entire room in yellow so
that the Green Lantern would have no
power that is one of the
best part like single issues of comic
history oh I know Jim Lee drawing Frank
Miller's
Insanity what the hell Batman painted an
entire room and wore yellow paint so
that the green face pted his own face
yellow so that the green laner would
have no power over him only and by the
way we don't even know if that's
true because post crisis Green Lantern
was not immune like like there was It
was kind of nebulous and like we don't
know if like Batman was legit at that
point yeah we don't even know like which
version of Green Lantern that is so like
it was just because Batman assumed that
he was a like you but it was before we
discovered that it was because of
Parallax and at the time he was still
just there was a yellow immunity a
yellow thing in there we don't know why
I've already I've only read the good
Frank Miller Batman I have not read any
of the crazy like Allstar Batman stuff
so you guys wonder why stuff's so
screwed up at DC oh no we don't like you
guys have like 50 versions of the same
person do I need to show this again do I
need to show the cover of the current
Futures End by the way if you want to
know what's going on in this cover at
some point I don't remember when in
Futures End Future Batman was sewn
together with future Joker by brother I
yeah it was like issue three or yeah and
and in this issue they're now sewn
together and this is them I guess Mr
terrific is now looking into the future
and sees a cut up Batman and Joker yeah
I'm not I'm not explaining Superman the
hell with that CU I'm not I'm not doing
that like that's that's nuts like all
that stuff you know what I'll stick with
Marvel characters I you know now I don't
know if I'll ever go as far as
explaining like madcap because I don't
want to talk about the voice Undead
person said Rob that's easy enough to do
you don't have to do DC videos but at
least read some stories that are known
to be good you guys are talking to me
about Superman who
sings sings a guy to death
you're telling you're telling me that
Superman who has all these Powers sings
a guy to
death that I read Superman no way no
there are good Superman stories I'm not
saying that's a good Superman story tell
man you should totally read uh if you if
you're even remotely
interested just read Superman Birthright
if you like it then you can continue if
you don't then you're never gonna like
Superman see I I don't know see like I
get to this point where like I see stuff
and I just I just write it off like for
example okay
so so looking at like like the X-Men
like X-Men one for example all right
like that movie was pretty decent like
you sit down you watch X-Men one and it
was pretty decent like you know it
starts off easy enough and then like the
movie descends into total Madness
because Magneto wants to turn everybody
into mutants and so like like I see
something like that I'm like okay that's
dumb and it's always going to be dumb in
my eyes now forever more and so I think
it'd be cool to read Superman but I
think the problem is if I sat down and
read Superman and and it turned out the
Superman is just like singing to
people that's one issue one issue that
he does the thing is like and he does it
good you need to read the good
Superman's yeah like you you need to
believe like the idea is that Superman
is like you know he's a Beacon of Hope
you believe in him and like if you like
Superman's earned the right to be able
to do that yeah like that's kind of like
Grant Morrison I think that's Grant
Morrison's point he's like you know like
Superman is the he's earned you the
right to be Scot stupid that is gr know
wait you're not Scottish you're from
Jersy no but he sounds like you just
insulted every Scottish person in
existence let me tell you something
sounds like what what are you s a
xenophobe yeah is that what is that what
you are now a xenophobe isn't that one
of the aliens and Aliens versus Predator
those are xen
xenom a xenophobe the xenophobes are
chasing us
xob we are so far off topic it's not
even funny so death The Wolverine is
every everybody's enjoying it we can
agree with that right death of wolver RS
okay I'm glad to see wolver Reign coming
to an end but it's by far it's it's
pretty far away from the best wolver
story I've ever read let me tell you
something I say is the best one in a
while Steve mcniven's art has never been
better oh that I agree with that I agree
there's I don't think there's really any
debate here on that did Dave just come
yeah excuse me got to go change my pants
oh Steve MCN
hard
first sink shn
SN sh I knew youying get swing
s it's like this like Wayne's World like
world is nothing Wayne's World party man
nobody even knows what that is anymore
okay all right Next Top what are they
talking about so exactly so um all right
uh anyway Death of Wolverine totally
worth picking up it's unfortunately
delayed and we're getting a Greg land
variant on the third issue or the fourth
issue great I don't I don't even care
about variants like I looked at the
variant covers for for Death of
Wolverine number one and there was like
eight or nine of them and some of them
were like $20 and I was like what why
the heck would you pay $20 for a single
comic let me tell you something one page
of it like oneing I don't know why I
mean VAR like a variant would have to be
exceptionally cool for me to go out and
get one like it'd have to be pretty just
make it your desktop wallpaper like why
do you need to have like a comic book
with that cool image like this is
another thing is like the main cover
that's like kind of like shimmery and
holographic is cool as it is it's right
yeah no that's that's the other thing is
that that book is the death Wolverine
collected like actually like printed is
so so pretty and it gets like you get
sketches you get little like
descriptions of what the writing was all
about you have this like theme of color
throughout the issues it's just like I
don't I except for that awful Rocket
Raccoon ad right in the first page you
hate those well it's so [__]
distracting like it he's just rocket and
it's such a crappy looking action figure
he's like and you're like that's not
even what he looks like that looks like
they they did it they did it in the
front so they didn't have to like stick
three in in the middle of the comment
right but don't put them in it all just
or do what IDW does and just shove them
all at the end like IDW and image books
just end with like four or five
different pages of ads like a magazine
in there well see it doesn't interrupt
the book that's why it's not upset to me
it's not upsetting to me when I I go
through a comic and and they're not like
in the middle because I mean you guys
remember like way back when like they
would be in the middle of it you'd go
through like three or four pages and it
was like do you want to become muscular
and it's like some guy on a beach
ad so
here here is the reason I think the
marketing strategy for having ads in the
front is better than in the back because
I'd imagine myself getting to the back
of a comic seeing ads and
going you know what you're actually 100%
right because in all honesty um I do a
lot of testing with the marketing on my
various channels on YouTube here and if
you put anything in the end anyone who
watches their attention realizes
everyone turns their video off like a
minute before the ending right anything
you're trying to PL no one watches so I
started plugging things in the
beginning and that worked and for the
record I bought that Rocky Raccoon thing
based upon that ad in that that magazine
so I bought that stat it's Benny's fault
that we have ads in comment I bought
that figure in the store and it's like
this big and it's dumb that's not dumb
dude have you seen my house you've seen
my background I'm gonna film all this
crap you know what I bought today a
Supergirl action figure sitting in my
bedroom why Wow cuz it go to the
collection cuz it goes to the collection
I mean what what why wouldn't I buy it
you know what you know what's look right
here I got Sylvanas from World of
Warcraft wow that I just broke her I
think you I got start doing you know
what I over here here's that Batman all
our toys if you can look at the
background that's the Batman Wonder uh
Catwoman kiss over there that I'm not
picking up because it was $400 oh I've
got my custom Xbox 360 controller
okay you were saying I I got you got
toxic what do youy
drink is a Ninja Turtle character I've
got my got my Gambit from Benny bought
that figure is is we're gonna get part
one and part two of issue certain
number and and it's going to be 10 pages
of ads in 10 pages of comic book and
they're going to be $5 a piece so you're
going to end up paying $10
yeah and getting 20 pages of
ads because Benny bought that one action
figure they w't go get it it's not here
yet I ordered off Amazon I'm waiting for
it to come in oh you actually oh thought
you were
trolling I really did I also got the one
where he's hanging out on
grp
Wow there is a really cool like I think
it's hot toys that's making a statue of
of Groot with with Rocket Raccoon on on
top and I want to get that Funko doing
one Bombshells line with the 1950s
appearance over there those are cool I
met dude I met the guy who sculpted
those he lives down the street he said
if I bring all my stuff I'll sign it
really [__] man yeah I be all over that
was there and he was sculpting the new
one the Black Canary one that hadn't
come out yet yeah and he and I was like
dude I love these I got them in my house
they're on display he's like you know
what I live over like down the street
from here if you just come by with the
statues I'll sign them that's awesome
okay yeah I mean I would I'd be like
okay like like five minutes and I'll be
back here let me let me buy 20 of this
one and and I'll sell
the um okay okay so getting us back on
topic yeah so we had a so our our topic
after the death of Wolverine is we want
to talk about the Punisher and it's
really more speculation than anything
else but having read original s video
huh did you read that V released your
video on The Punisher no oh oh Rob's got
it was supposed to be a surprise you ass
you just ruined it
thank okay fine guys I'm I'm gonna do a
video about The Punisher after Infinity
Gauntlet but that's ruined it here's my
question you're gonna do the part where
the Punisher was recruited by God and
angels gave him a angel gun I'm I'm
leaving that out and I'm leaving out
Punisher MAX well Punisher MAX is the
only damn good I I I know but the
problem with Punisher
like Punisher MAX is so adult oriented
like like literally there's like
Punisher MAX issue number 24 somebody
somebody bust into Frank Castle's
apartment and he jumps out of bed and
like his girlfriend like the chicken bed
her tits are hanging out like like Max
is like the adult oriented imprint for
Marvel so I'm not sure I'm gonna like
have boobs plastered all over my YouTube
channel that's true I might I might just
go ahead like I might make a thing ahead
of the time like before the video and
say like this video has like adult
oriented material because I feel like
with the Punisher if I'm going to do the
Punisher explain like it's got to be
like The Punisher like
violence bloody and gory and crap and
you don't have to show the panels with
tits that's or you just black bar sens
to them it'll be funnier yeah that would
be
fun I'll teach you how to do tracking
and after effects yeah you have to teach
me how to do tracking and after effects
I don't know how to do that but all
right so after reading original sin am I
the only one around here that wants to
see like a team up with Punisher and
Rocket Raccoon no you were not I I would
love to see that was not a good team up
oh dude punish sure and Doctor Strange
was not that was not cool as I was
hoping it was going to be yeah it was
just it was kind of expected Dr Strange
being like you disgust me yeah who
destroys whole planets I me that's
pretty that's pretty much it like like
he was like there's no difference
between you and the person who's like
killed countless people and like
organisms and planets like you're pretty
much the same person I'm like what a
shitty thing to say to a person it's
true I real have in the title what we're
supposed to be talking about what are
you talking yeah like death Punisher and
all new X-Men and but anyway so Punisher
no no I wasn't winging it yeah it's in
the title um I mean just because it's in
the title doesn't mean like we're only
going to talk about what's in the title
it's just like here's a general idea of
what may or may not be talked about
during this
podcast but um but no yeah I I really
want to see a rocket Rec even if it's
only for like like five issues or six
issues like a limited series run it one
shot yeah even it's one hilarious see
Punisher in space with Rocket Raccoon
especially you take like the Scotty
young storyline there's a thousand one
different aliens yes here's my pitch
here's my pitch Punisher Rocket Raccoon
drawn by Scotty young written by ganis
go yeah sold I'll buy I mean it's not
going to be bad well you know I got
think of somebody who's not as high risk
as garan is CU Garis could be either
great or horrible but here's the thing
about garnis though like if you put
garnis on a project like this you're
talking about like Rocket Ron who
already has like a huge fan base just
just by virtue of the movie Guardians of
the Galaxy and then Punisher who is just
an incredibly violent guy and kills
criminals indiscriminately yep no he's
got like a crazy fan base yeah yeah I
mean but but I'm saying like he's he's
got a cult following kind of thing I
know people who will only buy Punisher
books oh yeah yeah but you but what are
you talking about like when you say like
fan bases for punisher like The Punisher
fan bases fall in the same line as like
Captain Marvel fan bases and or like
like I would say Not N audiences yeah
Niche audiences they're their cult their
cult followings like Howard the Duck fan
bases people who were like yes is there
a fan base for Howard the Duck yeah
there's a fan base for Howard the Duck
like I'm one of them I hope there are
more like really you were complaining
when you went through the Howard D story
like I don't even know if I should put
this out an adult fan base for action
figures yes I don't know I don't know
who would buy action figures one of them
is in the middle of this screen right
now shut up but um but no like yeah
there's there's a really there's like a
niche following for punisher and it's
it's a c quot following kind of thing so
you've got people who are huge fans of
both characters of Rocket Raccoon of
Punisher and so on and I think that if
you were to combine these two things
together then you would have an
incredible combination and this is why I
think Marvel screwed up by having having
Bucky Barnes be the man on the wall
because by having Frank hassle play the
man on the wall that means now he can be
part of the space fairing conflicts he
can just show up in the middle of some
space event with rocket wakon and just
start wiping stuff out but I think
that's the problem because okay you take
Bucky bar you take Bucky and you put him
out there and you do all this crazy crap
that's kind of expected of Bucky when
the first thing came up we were all like
Bucky's gonna be the guy to do it winter
soldier does crazy time travel and he's
been uh you know changed around and
worked with the Nick Fury before The
Punisher as far as I can remember has
never had any really out there
storylines it's
always there's a book called Franken
Castle oh okay well all right we're not
talking about Frank Castle I
want it's built directly in with Siege
do Wolverine's bisexual
son kills and slices up Punisher and
dumps him in the sewer but then like I
think the morlocks or something like
pick up his pieces and then he and then
like a bunch of like Supernatural
characters like man thing and werewolf
by night and stuff like put him back
together and like Frankenstein him up
because they need to use him to like
kill whatever was bothering them it's
people said it was the most fun they've
had reading Punisher books in years I
thought it was other than that other
than that Punisher has never had like
you've never seen Punisher in like a
major space fairing crossover event cuz
he he's out of place The Punisher does
he use laser gun crazy is like I've got
a shotgun why is the alien not dying I
agree I agree and that's why that's why
Punisher MAX was so good because of that
because it was just like Punisher just
killing criminals that's all it was it
was just Daredevil isn't up there either
why we could put daredevil on something
crazy Daredevil barely leaves Hell's
Kitchen yeah yeah I think it's because
nobody leads him out of there since he's
blind but hey
whatever I mean he's in San Francis he's
in he's wh he's on the west coast now is
he part of like West Coast Avengers now
no there's no West Coast
Avengers West CO there AR anymore
there's what there's superheroes
fighting on the west coast they may not
be West Coast Avengers there used to be
a chapter of the West Coast Avengers but
that's closed are there any superheroes
for Ohio there used to be a team hang on
uh the uh50 initiative based out of let
me let me see who who that was on
initiative I want to get the r and cow
milker
manist Avengers they they did there was
a list for all 50 states I don't
remember who they were yeah I know that
you had I know in Las in Las Vegas I
think you had um the
Thunderbolts um in New York you had like
the like the most important people
basically yeah the Thunderbolts were
Colorado I think Colorado that's what it
was Colorado Okay Ohio was made up of
Agents of armor whose job it was to
protect the Earth 616 from threats from
alternate realities Howard the
Duck really is sent to find machine man
wow oh this is awesome this is a great
team machine man no wonder we man was in
Marvel Zombies yes he was traveling to
try to stop the zombies from getting to
the 616 yeah and uh Howard the Duck had
a cameo at the end of the first Marvel
Zombies publication when he was like he
was eating somebody I don't remember who
okay I need to ask your guys' opinion on
this real quick so I've been getting
slammed like crazy with re quest to do
Marvel Zombies which I'm going to do for
Halloween that's my Halloween book yeah
it's a good idea now I've started I've
read all the Marvel Zombies I need your
opinions on this technically can can and
wise the Marvel zombies are dead IES
from Army of Darkness yes yes are we
ignoring that technically um I would not
like the way I would explain it is you
would have to tie it in with dark you
have Dark Comics and Ash traveling to
the uh because remember remember like
the Marvel Zombies started out in an
alternate reality of the Marvel Universe
of the they're separ but the but the
Marvel Zombies basically did their
entire run of them just being Zombies
going into space going Cosmic zombie and
all that other crap then they came out
with the Army of Darkness tie-in where
we find out that apparently Ashton
Spiderman started this whole thing and
it's technically deadites yes yes and
everyone hates that book and that's that
well I mention it just for the sake of
saying like here's what Marvel and Dark
Horse are saying yeah but this is how it
started I kind of liked it I thought it
was like kind of fun I thought yeah I
thought it was really fun I thought I
lik the book but I was because and I was
going to throw it in there but after
doing research on opinions on Canon and
like everyone's like we ignore that book
yeah they usually do but like it's
stupid anyway it's still a part of the
story well it's also like like just
because it's bad doesn't mean you like
instantly omit it yeah but Tech because
it came out so late after the series
though that's why I'm thinking we could
technically just yeah you if you do that
then they never really explain where the
zombie virus began yeah and that's fine
you don't really need to know because
like yeah sometimes zombies just happen
man yeah just just like last week over
in h New Jersey I heard you were
fighting them with the baseball bats
it's true I was uh I was leading the
revolution against the zombie uprising
thankfully you know we Prevail that's
why we didn't have a podcast last week
uh s exactly right I'm sorry to say you
didn't get bitten did you
oh I mean like I got a scratch or
something but I mean well you got I mean
if you just like Lop off your arm it'll
be fine but if you guys want to see the
video of like s fighting the zombies you
can find a TV little house like like he
was he was swinging a bar wire baseball
bat and recording it with an iPhone at
the same time it was the most Beast
thing basically you can't find it watch
if you can't find it watch every video
we've ever made and then like every it's
an N bumper on a random video and he
doesn't remember which one he put it on
it may be two years back on the channel
yeah code yeah you have to like every
video and then it'll then the video if
I'm wrong though you got to get all your
friends to subscribe to the channel and
then like
it and buy a t-shirt sell sell for bu a
t-shirt set it up but um but yeah it's
like what I would do here is according
to sry breaking news Deadpool movie will
be released in February 2016 huh let's
see about that yeah let's see about that
all right as you were saying rob I just
want to throw that in there real quick
yeah what I what I would say here is if
you plan on explaining Marvel zombies um
there's a lot of ground to cover I me
you're talking about like tiin to Marvel
Zombies so you're talking about when
Reed Richards and Dr Doom switch mindes
and that's your channel when you do
Marvel Zombies I'll admit all of that
and just be like the zombies ain't the
people and they put they put the son of
black panther they put his brain in
Captain America's body they put his
brain in Captain
America zie that jumped
somebody right transition in Marvel
zombies and that that's after the whole
earth gets consumed by the the zombie
infestation they eat galatis and then
they they start flying I love that I
love that Galactus shows up like the
silver surface shows up and they eat him
and then Galactus shows up and he was he
was yeah he was like what happened like
where is the herald he's like and
Spiderman's like are you talking about
the guy in silver and they he was like
yes they like we ate him and Galactus is
like
what G and they travel the universe
eating planets yeah they I honestly I
love that irony of like I don't really
like Marvel Zombies but that moment of
galatis being consumed was
amazing but they start they started
attacking each other like is the first
book and I think the second book are
great yeah and then decided to not
continue that story for the four third
and fourth books and then the fifth book
goes back to those guys yeah it it it
got a little crazy but okay so if you're
going to skip all the times and stuff
like that then I would just say that
it's some point along the line Marvel
and Darkhorse got together and said it
was explained by you know the deadites
and like Ash and the the Army of
Darkness but you could just kind of
mention well you know whether or not you
consider this to be Canon is up to you
or something like that exactly it's say
yeah this is what this is what they're
stating you decide if you want this or
not I mean Marvel Zombies was a it was a
really fun story to read it was a great
fun story like I enjoyed it I had a
great time reading it I think they kind
of milked that cow till it was dead but
oh yeah it came out of the perfect time
like zombie craze was nuts Robert kman
wrote it yeah it was it was awesome yeah
yeah the The Walking Dead Guy yeah okay
so I put us on completely different
tangent but that was based off a comment
someone said so by the way I will uh
build off of that apparently it's true
the Deadpool movie according to the
Hollywood Reporter is happening February
2016 Tim Miller is still attached to
direct the project with no deal set for
a long-term star because Ryan Rey's kind
of dropped out but we don't know
anything about that so the only thing we
know is Deadpool for 2016 February um
Tim Miller is going
direct huh thought he wanted to come
back like he's been up and down like
superer Su probably like he's probably
fool me once shame on like you like I
don't know if it's ever gonna happen
like yeah I don't know man if I were
Ryan Reynolds I would stand by any
possibility of playing a playing
Deadpool because that's like I mean that
would solidify him as the CU he was a
great Deadpool and he was a great Green
Lantern the story around him sucked ass
oh my God you're so full of crap Benny
he was terrible ring
finger it was it was is ring
finger who else has a green Lon ring at
their desk I
don't I I looked for a really nice one
because I wanted one and I just I
couldn't I couldn't find it I'm a
grownup so I don't have so if any if any
of you guys happen on a com
guys if any of you guys happen upon a
really nice Green Lantern ring for a
good price that isn't like $300 I'll
send you this one it's plastic yeah
those I can get for free I'll get you
hold on hold on I just need to I just
need my plastic green lanter I have the
ones that came out with the Blackest
Night with the lanterns and stuff I'm
still yeah that was cool I got a Black
Lantern ring somewhere um
but yeah so so the rumor mill about the
Punisher in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is that he was driving like the
yellow Pinsky truck that's the way it's
being circulated like Marvel's saying
that the fact that he showed up twice in
the same movie and most part like showed
up I guess maybe ass cist Captain
America or to the very least maybe cause
some like confusion among what was going
on was that it was not accidental what
movie uh Captain America the Winter
Soldier really there's a yellow Pinsky
truck that that makes that makes two
appearances and uh Marvel is saying like
during the special the special features
Marvel was saying that was not an
accident like they intentionally put it
in there and supposedly the rumor is
that they're setting that up for Frank
Castle because Marvel got the rights
back to Frank Castle in 2012 so yeah I'm
curious like if we see the Punisher in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe there's
two things they need to do one they need
to give him Netflix because they can set
the character upgrade and they can do
whatever they want with this character
in Netflix people are paying to see it
so it doesn't abide by you know censors
or anything like that and so they can
have like down home violent gratuitous
horrible Frank Castle just killing
people arbitrarily and torturing them
and that would be the Frank Castle
everybody knows and loves and then they
could build off that and then just have
them in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and show up at some point in time I
don't know I hope just like uh house of
cards they put out the the Marvel
Cinematic Universe stuff on Blu-ray too
yeah cuz I'm a I'm a sucker for having a
physical copy of stuff it makes sense I
mean people like to like to be able to
collect that stuff but um but yeah
that's what Marvel was saying about uh
about the Punisher is that they've been
setting it up so that he's going to be
in there and so I'm really hoping that
we see and and I want to see Thomas Jane
come back Thomas Jane was a great pun
see I would love to see that he is so
good I like that last movie I loved what
what that last Punisher movie One War Z
that was awful and that wasn't I didn't
like it at I liked that one I thought he
was a great Punisher and the story was
just down to earth and it's kind of like
the last judge
was a good actor really good if you want
to see like a really good Punisher go
watch uh laundry day yeah on YouTube
like that's it's Thomas Jane and it's
like this like eight minute long video
and it is so awesome that's the Punisher
I want to see on Netflix it's also by
the way made by the same guy who did
dread so like that's why it feels so
good yeah like I'm I'm it's it's violent
too man like he breaks the guy's arms
and legs and then like he sits he sits a
lighter down in front of him and then
like the hooker that that guy be up like
walks up and just like throws it on him
and like like he just burns a lot
awesome yeah amazing it The Punisher I
think would be it would be such a great
reveal I like Punisher could show up in
a Captain America movie that' be fine
but I'd much rather see him be like a
story arc in the Netflix Marvel series
like because they're making Luke Cage
Daredevil Jessica Jones and I think
ironfist yeah and then and they're each
going to get their own series like
season and then they're going to do
another season after that of them on a
team called the Defenders I would love
to see a thread throughout that Series
be the Punisher like that there's this
crazy guy in a black T-shirt with a
skull on that keeps murdering people in
their in their zones it could fit in
Netflix best place for and then if it
works they could easily just be like and
a Punisher show cuz it costs like $1 an
episode to make a guy with a black
T-shirt kill people like that's nothing
so like do it and it doesn't even mean
to be like like in your face it can just
be like like on the news like a mass
vigilante you know has been spotted
killing somebody or
something n descript dude murdering
people here's what I'm wondering in
terms of like what's going on on the
other side of of the fans is who's who's
paying who is is Netflix paying Disney
for the rights to make these things is
there some kind of exch like Netflix is
paying Disney some amount of money to
host these things I have no idea I think
it was they were being asked like they
they they were like we want to make a
show and Netflix like probably won the
bid like we'll do it yeah Netflix is
like buying everything and you know what
I'm not even gonna lie so far I've liked
almost everything they've done I even
watched horse Bojack and that was good
house of cards ising and that's one of
the first TV series to ever be sh on a
4k camera fun fact that show is hands
downan Bojack does not beat House of Cs
but it is still a good Netflix
show the only the only thing they've
made that kind of sucks was Lily Hammer
that like mobster in another region I
didn't mind it but I lost interest like
a good ways into it like I got like I
think a little over halfway and I just
stopped watching yeah I just heard
negative thing I was like people were
just like skip it and I'm like okay it
was just one of those ones that was just
kind of took so long to really get
anything going and it wasn't even like
Netflix original it was actually out
elsewhere and they just bought it for
the US
release I mean it's and I I didn't like
the Arrested Development season whatever
they did people didn't really like that
at all so because they did one day the
whole thing is one day and what everyone
did on this one day so have 13 episodes
of one
day they also they also have Agent
Carter coming up in ABC yeah I'm excited
which I'm excited
about he was just saying that that's
coming out between Shield like I guess
when Shield goes on a Christmas break
that comes
out yeah yeah
um I'm just wondering if like Howard
Stark is gonna show up in that oh they
they cast him yeah yeah yeah like the
show is supposed to revolve around like
the foundation of Shield more or less
like how shield got started I think
Howard start be like a main character
yeah is the same guy from the movie or
do we recast same guy from the movie
like the young guy from Captain America
the First Adventure awesome yeah yeah
but yeah I'm I'm I'm I'm pretty excited
I'm pretty excited about it because for
a couple reasons one because again like
I'm glad to see that that um Agent
Carter is going to get some
representation and two because the chick
that plays Agent Carter is really
hot why do you always gotta make things
creepy haly Atwell man that is my home
girl that's good to know that's you do
all that's what makes it creepy the
peace sign does not help does yes it
does but uh but no I'm I'm I'm just I'm
really excited because I like that
Marvel's going back and explaining how
like the early days of shield and how
like the whole thing came to fruition
and like in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because I like reading about
and and like seeing that kind of stuff
where they talk about like like history
and whatnot so I'm I'm pretty psyched
but I think that um that agent Carter
has the potential to be amazing it just
depends on what Marvel does with it
because Marvel's notorious for having
really good ideas and then screwing them
up yeah so they haven't up until this we
had a we had a few filler movies but
they weren't horrendous like I wouldn't
I wouldn't tell anyone don't go watch
Iron Man 2 just only watch it once yeah
but I I would tell people Iron Man 3 is
like you don't really need to watch that
movie you don't need to see you need to
watch IR Man 2 was fun at least you got
Sam Rockwell being hilarious yes he was
so
funny more I was so disappointed that
Justin Hammer was not a man antagonist
on Agents of Shield like I'm so so
disappointed that they didn't like oh
wouldn't it have been great here's the
thing just this is pretty much for Rob
and maybe some people in the chat who
know marvel but wouldn't it have been
great if they had made Justin Hammer the
head of the roxson
corporation that would have made perfect
sense to me I mean
see a lot of a lot of friends of mine
and a lot of what I see on the internet
is that the excuse for Agents of Shield
not showing more development in the
actual story and showing cool stuff is
that they wanted to establish all of the
characters yeah and that's fair in the
first season and that that's okay it was
it was the Weeden method that's what he
did in all his old shows the problem the
problem is and the reason why I don't
think asent of shield did too well the
first season at least the first half of
the season is the Weeden method was
great when we had shows that were doing
that it Blended in well Buffy and Angel
came out at a time we were just getting
lost we were just getting all these
shows with constant continuities and
building of characters and stuff like
that that's the we method of doing
things and now in 2013 when that came
out we don't really the the viewing
public likes to just get to the bang as
quick as possible lost ruined the
general viewing public because nobody
wants to invest time hoping it's going
to pay off anymore yeah yeah well series
the entire series ended like crap it's
like oops well you're all dead anyway so
exactly and that's why nobody wants to
spend all this time investing for a big
payoff that we may or may not get at the
end yeah I liked what they did with
shield and I'm like disappointed
that people are like the Sith episode's
the best episode I'm like that was a fun
episode yeah but that's not I don't want
it like no it's no like we don't need
just n non-stop cameos of superpowered
characters and our main characters being
like well that person's really effective
look at her do some stuff like no you
just want to watch Avengers like that's
what the Netflix shows are for if you
want to see superheroes teaming up and
fighting other people then you're going
to watch Avengers Avengers 2 you're
going to see maybe Captain America 3
like you know and you're watch the
Netflix shows but if you want to see
like well apparently you don't want to
see Regular People existing in the
Marvel universe so you know that's not
that's not for you like n but the show's
never going away oh no I'm sure Shield
season two will be nonstop I'm sure that
they'll just be but like yeah you can't
have Iron Man because he's only got one
picture in him and like in his contract
so yeah you know you're not going to get
Iron Man you're not going to get uh
Chris Evans he doesn't want to act
anymore you're not going to get no I
thought Chris Evans said that
mind being around for a few more Captain
am movies good I don't know the
particulars I don't know the particulars
of uh the the contract of course but I
would assume that they could like show
Iron Man in the show like just CGI the
crap out of him yeah and just have him
in his Iron Man suit and just have him
voice I don't know if that counts as an
appearance they just clip his his voice
but they like they like basically like
uh what's that sound board him in oh oh
no the movies yeah
but I mean it oh no oh no Whiplash is
coming to kill me no think that I don't
think that fits here man oh the Crimson
Dynamo well you know I mean you know I I
get that I need to get this this core
reactor removed from my
chest I I'm I I would be curious I'm
curious what Marvel's going to do
because Marvel with I don't know why
they did this but with Iron Man Marvel
took a sealess character and just made
him like super popular and just hyped
him up because Iron Man was never that
popular like for those of you guys for
those of you guys that never that don't
read Marvel Comics or don't know a whole
lot about Iron Man Iron Man was a almost
irrelevant character like the only time
he was ever relevant was during Civil
War and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and then he was just bam he was huge
only real relevance Tony Stark had
before the movie and made him huge was
he was the superhero who had the money
yeah that was that was his relevance
yeah he was Bank rolling everything that
was kind of his whole thing and I I
don't even like his current story lines
I keep trying to jump into it and I
don't like where they're going with him
right now I've tried to get into Iron
Man Comics since the movie and I can
never get into any of not that good of a
character he's not it's like his his
Rose Gallery sucks his character is
difficult to get behind because either
he's a douche or he's a tool and like so
which version do you want like or he's
of
mistakes yeah he he just screws
everything
up I mean even then he's a dick about it
later he's like oh yeah that happened
but that that happened before I mean
it's not necessarily so much that but it
is like like how often do you really
want to read a comic about a guy like
like original sin like I talked about
this during my Hulk versus Iron Man my
my Hulk versus Iron Man video and this
is what I didn't like about Marvel Mar
because the question was well why is it
that like if Tony Stark was the one
responsible for Bruce Banner becoming
the Incredible Hulk in 1962 why does he
remember that Marvel was just like well
you
know that's that's like they they wrote
it off they just said well you know he
drinks
alcohol black out yeah reasons they're
just like with it like just here's just
like a really lazy explanation and just
write it off his Z I'm like that's so
lazy that's just the Lazi like well he
was an alcoholic and he just blacked out
and forgot like how do you forget how do
you forget that much the way they do it
is he knew he knew what he had done um
but like it was still hazy as to what
had happened with the whole thing but
because he was drinking during that time
and they they make it very clear that at
every panel in the 1960s he's holding
the liquor bottle yeah he
was right always got a martini or like
some kind of thing to establish that he
has an alcohol problem right and and the
way they pretty much do it CU I mean I
just did the video for it and and though
I even I even kind of explained it is he
did Tinker with it to hurt the Hulk but
when Bruce Banner sees drunk Tony Hulk
tinkering with the bomb drunk Tony
Hulk Tony
smash but he assumes that Tony Stark
made the bomb do what it did yep and
it's the that's I mean without spoiling
my own video that's kind of how it
resolves well you know what you spoil my
Punisher thing so I'm gon to spoil your
video that's pretty much that's pretty
much you're surprise mine's
out I mean the way the way they
explained it in terms of like his
involvement I thought was that was cool
you know like that he was involved with
it and and that was interesting but the
problem hold on hold on hold on gumy
Garcia says that if I narrated porn I'd
make billions of dollars people are
apparently talking about how sexy my
voice is I didn't realize
it should dude dude just do me a fa do
fa just be like hello ma'am I'm here
with the pizza you need it's got extra
sausage
say say it say
it don't do it dance monkey dance all
right hold
on somebody recort this for sound oh my
God it's so funny hold on I can't stop
laughing all right hold on I'm sound
biting this all right um all right what
do you what is it you want me to say
okay you got to say hello ma'am I'm here
with your pizza and it has extra a
sausage you got you got to do the proper
pause there yeah you got to really give
the Cadence okay hold on hold
on this is
ridiculous hello ma'am I brought your
pizza and it has extra
sausage get inside oh my
God where is this going what have we
done the we P podcast after hours I
don't know
this
is saying before let me get back on
topic here let's get back on topic was
less out of character for Tony Stark to
not want to mention that he tinkered
with the bomb while drunk yeah and more
out of character for Bruce Banner to
immediately go to I'm going to come up
with Hyper intelligent Hulk and go Crush
Tony and not even ask him about this
that that was that was that was silly to
me especially when they talked about how
like the incredible Hook was smart now
like so the incredible Hook's smart now
thanks to like extremists more or less
but like he was smart in the 90s too
like he's you know what yeah but the way
they're playing it off now is like like
there's there's a particular point in
the con in the story where they're out
in the desert like after he like crushes
Iron Man's suit and wraps it around him
which is pretty
awesome but um but he's just like you
are going nowhere Tony sm's just like
sitting there held down by a suit and
and he tells him like like let me just
get to a less angry State and he calms
down and he becomes a r spanner so like
I don't know if maybe this means he can
control himself now like the The Hulk
control when he changed which I hope is
not the case because that's like a
staple it's proven by the end because
Bruce Banner has to go get
held can't turn back he just can't turn
back Hulk I was I was like that's one of
the things that makes shehulk unique and
I really hope they don't take that away
but um but nonetheless I think that was
more on a character because okay s you
turn into a green hulking monster and
you find out that I may have had an
involvement in it your first answer is
kill me you don't even want to just chat
on the phone hey right this weird flash
that you may have turned me into the
Hulk I just know truth behind that yeah
but if I knew you were a big fat
liar like Tony Stark is I might be more
inclined to like beat the information
out of you yeah I mean especially if I'm
beating the information out of him I
mean banner even says I thought you'd be
dead when I turned back like there was
no to beat it out like he is a giant
rage monster so I mean like maybe wasn't
really thinking clearly like maybe the
Hulk was kind of like helping him
develop this Revenge plot I don't know I
mean there were some cool points too
like there was one point where Iron Man
was fighting Hulk and uh I think when he
put on his Hulkbuster armor and he was
saying something to the effect of like
like there's got to be a limit to his
strength or something like that and the
Hulk shows up and he says always The
Optimist Tony and then he just like
smashes his Hulkbuster armor no says oh
goody another suit of armor for me to
yeah that's what that's what it is yeah
yeah he just like crushes his whole
Buster armor I mean he destroyed like
that was he and we know that he's going
to do it cuz like in World War Hulk Iron
Man had that awesome Hulkbuster armor
yeah that that he smashes immediately
like come on yeah like well even in that
story I actually glazed over this part
because because it was more of just the
fist punching and everything but Tony
Stark used a whole city against the Hulk
in that book series yeah the city I
guess what it's called iron Metropolis
or something like that he got everyone
out of there and used every weapon on
the Hulk and the Hulk was just like
whatever yeah nothing happened and and I
mean there were there were some cool
moments but at the end of it all like
like that's that's the question that I
ask when I read a tiean when I read
something like Hulk versus Iron Man at
the end of it all what do we learn like
what's what's the Grand Puba what's the
big thing here well all we learn is that
Tony Stark was still an alcoholic that
Tony Stark had basically contributed to
Bruce Banner becoming the Incredible
Hulk by not telling him or by Bruce
Banner not reading the email saying well
you know this scamma radiation is
probably going to turn you into
something but we don't really know what
it is yeah I mean well I I think it has
less to do with I think more of the
purpose of the story is this is the
reason why Banner decided to risk
extremist and become intelligent Hulk
and this is gonna lead to intelligent
Hulk storylines that's what I think I
think that's what we're going to get out
of this I hope not I mean I don't want
to see Savage Hulk anymore I mean Savage
Hulk is cool but after a while you just
it gets boring seeing a Hulk just like
smash stuff up there's really I mean
that's one of the biggest problems
people have with the Hulk but the other
side of this is are going to take it
back to the 19 what is it 1998 or
something like that like super smart
geneticist Hulk I mean are they're gonna
take I think that's where we're going at
this right now because he he has the
intelligence of banner and the strength
of Hulk again yeah but see I I don't I
don't know I don't know how I feel about
this because the Hulk's all right but I
mean they they got to give him something
because out of all of the big
superheroes that Marvel has the Hulk's
probably one of the biggest ones they
have the Hulk has the least amount of
story you can go with you can give Tony
Stark more villains that'll make it
worth it you can give him a plot that
enough Iron Man fans will read you can
give Thor a plot involving going to the
10th realm you can make Captain America
young again what do you do with the Hulk
he turns big and green and smashes
everything right but that's the problem
that you have with a character like Hulk
when you when you sit down and you say
okay here's a character who's massive in
size there's no limit to how strong he
can get like that's why he's a great
support character he's horrible main
character I've read the Hulk stories is
when he's in Avengers versus X-men or
he's in Age of Ultron it's incredible oh
the Hulk's the big gun bring them out
you know yeah but but where do you go I
mean yeah what could you really do in
terms of a story involving the
incredible Hulk like like okay here's
here's an idea name me a foe that the
Incredible Hulk could go against
consistently and that would still make
an interesting
story the best one and they can't even
go back there anymore no the best one
they did was when they reverse bursted
and banner went criminally insane and
the Hulk was the primary personality and
then when the Hulk Cal down he would
black out into a criminally insane
banner and banner was setting up the
Hulk to try and kill him yeah but you're
you're talking about a reversal of the
status like you're talking about a
reversal they do not like Banner is the
one that's going out and committing
crimes and and fighting like people are
fighting Banner they're not really
fighting the Hulk no it was the Hulk
fighting himself Banner acted like
himself but what no one realizes that he
went insane and was trying to kill the
Hulk so what would happen is Banner
would would position the Hulk in in
locations to get what he wanted and in
the end it turned out Banner was trying
to cure himself of the Hulk and
therefore kill the Hulk yeah and so what
he was doing was he would stage
situations like the Hulk would turn back
into the Hulk and he would be an
Atlantis and trying to fight against
Neymar and all them to get to work out
some deal that Banner had worked out
then he would go unconscious again wake
up in space fighting Russian space Bears
trying to get some kind of like Cosmic
Cube thing he would and that that was
probably the most interesting Hulk story
I've read in the last couple of years
yeah but so that's the problem that you
run into is you have like these single
issue or little maybe like limited
issues or even like World War Hulk where
you have a series where he just comes
back to Earth after being you know
exiled and then just starts tearing
stuff up but was a great story too yeah
it was but the problem you have here is
there's no character that you can name
me that the Hulk can fight consistently
day in and day out or that can be
involved in an ongoing storyline that
would be interesting yeah no you're
right like I've never been able to be
convinced that the Hulk can be an
interesting character like consist
that's why his movies suck I mean as
much as I like his movies they suck at
the same time because he doesn't have
any interesting villains to go up
against there's no also like his his
main goal is to cure himself of the
thing that makes him interesting like
right I I don't want the Hulk to succeed
in his goal but I need to be able to be
interested in him succeeding in his goal
like I have to believe he can do it but
I know they won't because they have to
sell Hulk books so like every so like
all the tension is destroyed yeah that's
why he's a great support character
horrible that's why he's a great Avenger
he is he is he's a great guy that only
needs to show up when there's just
there's something going on they just
need his help for something it's like
everybody's wondering why we don't have
another Hulk movie again and the reason
is the first two did shitty because it's
hard to tell a story about the Hulk I
mean they're gonna do it they're they're
giving Mark Buffalo his own they're
talking they're talking about like a
like a plan Hulk type movie yeah have to
be something like that there's so few
stories to work with are I mean see a
cool planet Hulk movie like that would
be cool I mean that's that's the problem
that you run into is I mean you're
talking about the Incredible Hulk that
has just such unfathomable strength like
the only people that can really go to
toe go Toe to Toe with him are like
Godly powerful characters like Thor Odin
or something like that I mean st's
writing a Thanos versus Hulk book that's
yes I heard about that I actually really
excited because that's that's the first
time actually since Infinity Gauntlet I
think that uh Hulk and Thanos will ever
go toe-to-toe and in fact it was
actually Hulk and draa Destroyer that
went Toe totoe with Thanos yeah and it
was woefully underpowered like Hulk was
nowhere near the level that he is
considered to be now yeah no not at all
so I'm I'm actually really excited
because there was actually a point in uh
in the Thanos Quest when I was going
over that where um he was fighting the
champion and when he was analyzing the
powers of champion he was talking about
how the powers of champion were similar
to the ho
and he mentioned how he's always tried
to avoid fighting the Hulk just because
he's so incredibly strong I got to tell
you man like like Jim Starlin um when
Benny made his video where he was
talking to Jason and they were talking
about um the Thanos uh re Revelation is
that what it was I think yeah re re the
book he promoted like crazy in the last
one dude that that book was so good I've
got to download I got to read it dude
it's it's so good like like it brings us
back Adam Warlock um which with Adam
Warlock comes the maggus and I don't
even know if they're even going to do
like goddess they're just setting up
more Guardians stuff aren't they pretty
much pretty much that's all they're
doing they're building on top of the
idea that people are like oh Adam
Warlock in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and so Marvel's like okay let's bring
him back which is high time they did it
anyway well apparently like that book
was was was controversial in its own
right because Starlin wanted to write
his own story with Adam Warlock and
Marvel's like no more Adam Warlock we
have no plans for him we don't want to
bring him back and Starin and Marvel had
like a big problem with each other and
then finally Marvel's like after
Guardians of the Galaxy dwell Marvel's
like all right fine and so like they
released or at least made infinity
Revelation like that book is like Marvel
had some opposition because they're like
we have plans for Thanos like I think
that Starin wanted to write that back
when Infinity was being conjured so like
you know star's like I want to tell a
cool story about Thanos and Adam Warlock
and blah blah blah and like they were
like no no we're not doing that [__]
anymore like we're doing Infinity stuff
like where Thanos is like this I don't
know he's like a main antagonist and
he's like much less complicated or
Cosmic it's much more about him being
like a world Destroyer like yeah all
right and then they just let him do
whatever he want to do anyway that makes
sense this is an interesting comment uh
Lord
kagami uh he says the only Hulk movie I
want to see is to tie up the loose ends
with abomination and leader yeah pretty
much like I I wouldn't mind that like
they could set up a good story with that
yeah they could man but honestly they
came out with a movie and they said
here's what happens to Abomination
afterwards and here's what happens to I
probably wouldn't go see it okay imagine
imagine this though I I know the second
movie might be a filler movie but
Marvel's done that plenty of times with
their with their sequel movies Iron Man
2 and uh what was another like Thor two
was kind of a like yeah Ste so so
like imagine Hulk goes from movie one to
Avengers to the Abomination and leader
like versus movie where that fight
destroys like an entire
city and then that gives the Avengers or
like the Illuminati or however they set
it up a reason to send Hulk off for the
third movie since they're doing a lot of
trilogies and do the planet Hulk World
Warhawk movie I don't know I mean see
the other thing you got to bear in mind
too is Marvel's kicking these ideas
around but Marv was looking towards like
this this single finite point which is
like The Infinity Gauntlet story line
what they do after that I don't know but
everything for the record I don't think
I've seen anything definitively State
the infinity you got Thanos Gathering
the infinity gems for all you know that
movie is going to open with Thanos and
The Infinity Gauntlet Hulk's going to
walk over take the gauntlet put it on
become super powerful make Planet Hulk
punch the world madap is going to show
up in everyone's head and you're going
to have to do a video on madcap I'm not
doing a video on madcap but people like
when we speculate yeah if that comes
true Marvel owes me
money but no I I I mean that seems to be
the direction they're moving over
towards and so it seems to me that if
they were to do something like that but
I mean I I don't know but see like
Guardians of the Galaxy was long after
Infinity Gauntlet and they're doing
Guardians of the Galaxy so I have
honestly I have no real idea what
Marvel's Grand POA ultimate picture is
but no I have no idea I've also watched
a couple other YouTube videos where they
they set up the idea of since
everybody's contracts seem to be
wrapping up that they're going to go and
say all right this is The Avengers
Trilogy now we've got the new Avengers
Trilogy right and they're going to kind
of like lightly set that up with some of
this side stuff with the Netflix series
and Agent Carter and you know all this
all this kind of stuff that's setting up
in the
periphery and then they're they're going
to come in and they're going to reboot
Boot and they're going to find a new
cast with different characters that are
still going to be entertaining and still
going to be able to you know hit with
the big boys yeah yeah and and then
maybe like during those movies they can
just reference the other Avengers like
yeah they did I have no idea what
they're doing they did a really cool in
uh in what's it called Earth's Mightiest
Heroes they did a really badass episode
where Kang the Conqueror uh wipes out
the current roster of the Avengers like
Thor Iron Man cap Lo everybody
disappears and they like I think he puts
them in like time or in a different
dimension or some crap but like
according to Jarvis's scanners like
they're hang on one
minute according to Jarvis's scanners
like The Avengers are dead and so Starks
New New Avengers protocol gets enacted
and like Wolverine Spider-Man the thing
uh yeah War Machine and a couple other
and Luke Cage and Iron Fist get called
and they are and and Stark's like
hologram shows up and he's like so I
called you because you've shown me at
some point or another that you're
badasses and so you're the Avengers now
go to the Tower and grab your [__] and
because something's probably gonna
destroy the world and you have to go
fight it and they team up and it's and
it's really cool a really good episode
it's a great episode and like they could
easily do that if they were we don't cuz
in like cuz what Avengers 3 is what like
2019 so like by then Sony will have
ruined the Spider-Man brand so Marvel
will have it back have well because yeah
rued already because Sony hasn't
released a Sinister 6 movie yet but
after they do and it failed and after
they released Spider-Man 3 in 2019 and
all the all the TV and the Black Cat
movie and the Ant May movie and the J
movie did they really announce an ant
May movie I'm just saying like May movie
I would love to see Sally Field just
like running around like worrying about
Peter Parker just pacing back and she
just going for her errands the big thing
that she has to do is go to the DMV for
the whole movie like stressing over like
final notices on our bills and stuff I
don't know what I'm going to do yeah
wouldn't that she's going to save the
orphanage yeah like wouldn't it be
terrific to just to just mine that that
rich deep well of Spider-Man characters
like crowler and Black Cat and Rocket
racer you could have them all come out
and you create a spider team like go
screw yourselves so when that fails and
they finally get it back they could
theoretically do that like so maybe I
mean like the reality is like you know
Robert Dy Jr has been on the fence
forever so like sometimes he's like well
I'm done which is why Iron Man 3 ends
with like that yeah but it's also like
but he's also said like maybe I might
want to do an Iron Man four and maybe I
might want to stick around but like in
five years probably not like I I think
what what Robert Downey Jr has going on
and he is he's kind of conflicted
because he has with with these big
budget movies a lot of time invested in
like you know researching like how to
act and like really getting into the
script and then being on set forever and
like you know all all this AAA like big
budget title stuff he has less time to
like do Indie movies and stuff like he
likes to do because he loves to do
independent movies where he doesn't get
paid as much but they're a lot easier to
do the judge is supposed to be an indie
film isn't it I think so yeah the judge
the judge the new one with him I don't
think he wants to by any means like ruin
what Marvel has going on like I don't I
don't think like restarted his career I
don't think he wants to screw that over
but at the same time he wants to move on
well I don't think it wants to be typ
cast I mean Mark Hamill is forever going
to be known as Luke Skywalker and you
know the Harry Potter kid is forever
going to be known The Joker he managed
to break out into the Joker oh God dud
he's the best Joker he was the best
Joker
ever yeah that's okay I'm because we're
we're we've hit like a thousand one
tangents and this is not an episode of
tangents located on TV little house all
during the week and if you want to watch
tangents and crazy stuff go check out TV
little L but anyway um I was just going
to move us over to all new Xmen because
I have no idea what you want to talk
about yeah uh so the all new X-Men were
Miles Morales is that what we're talking
about because I the new X-Men run into a
mutant who can send people to the
Ultimate Universe and so the all new
X-Men aka the X-Men from the Past who
might also be from an alternate reality
go get sent to the Ultimate Universe so
you've got like young Beast Young Angel
young Jean Gray and
x23 and they go to the Ultimate Universe
and it looks like they're trapped there
and in typical Bendis ultimate Style it
is like two pages of it is like two
minutes of dialogue and it will it it'll
come out like three months later than it
should you know what the Ultimate
Universe has become now the Spider-Man
story and it's great Ultimate Universe
is is has been and always will be just a
Spiderman here no you know okay you know
what the Ultimate Universe is the
ultimate universe is that episode of The
Twilight Zone called It's a Wonderful
Life I think or something like that
where that kid like just keeps sending
people to the corn fields whenever they
whenever like they do stuff he doesn't
like
G to the
ultimate go to the cornfields go to the
UL Universe watch out will kill you this
is Jean Gray getting the entire Miles
Morales storyline in one go yeah yeah
it's great I mean it's it's cool but
what I was hoping see this is what I was
really hoping with because miles more
Alice has actually grown on me a little
bit yeah I I will say like I want to
into the into the 616 that's what I'm
saying that's exactly his team in
Spider-Man was great he doesn't he
doesn't need to be Spider-Man he could
be like some spin-off of Spider-Man or
something but there so many they've got
the the the Kane is still Spider-Man
you've got 2099 who's in the current
Universe you got regular Spider-Man uh
you know and like all that other garbage
from spider-verse but like yeah like
it'll be neat to like Jeff lob is so
totally effed the the ultimate X-Men
that you might as well just take young
X-Men from the 616 and send them over to
the Ultimate Universe and see how they
deal with it because why not right can't
be any worse yeah and they've also they
they have that awful uh Wolverine Sun
character that they
introduced
who no no no anything with the Ultimate
Universe
regard there's a guy whose name is like
I think his name is James too but he's
like this Rudy annoying character um you
can kill him and then you could just
make x23 the Wolverine of the Ultimate
Universe and it would that'd be fine
hell you could make x23 the Wolverine of
the 16 616 Universe be happy she's with
isn't she yeah the universe too yeah
well that was that was a funny thing
because people were getting like really
psyched up like when like Marvel Fox
came out and fox said well we're
bringing cable into the mar into the fox
universe and people were like yeah we
get to see cable and they're like but
it's the ultimate Universe cable and
they're like that's wolver
rain yeah that's just Wolverine from the
future you jerks that's not cable at all
no it's it's ultimate cable and ultimate
Cable's just even cooler cuz it's
Wolverine and Wolverine is super cool
yeah is he really wait I don't know
nothing about the Ultimate Universe
ultimate cable is just Wolverine yeah
from the future yeah from the future
yeah okay the way the way the okay the
way the Ultimate Universe is done it's
it's it's it's so incredibly stupid
Wolverine is like the first mutant I
think and he's the Catalyst for all the
other mutants and then like Nick Fury
was the Super Soldier like he was like
Captain America I think in the Ultimate
Universe
and so it's it's something to do with
like their blood being being spliced I I
don't know like it's it's it's
dumb all I'm hearing from you guys is
that Wolverine's GNA come back in the
comics and he's going to create a bunch
of
Inhumans man you know what that's your
theory I wouldn't doubt that the way
that that people are doing stuff but
okay so Curtis blowfield said something
I didn't even remember like I didn't
even realize he said that Drax
introduced himself as the one above all
at the beginning at the bar scene of
Guardians of the Galaxy what that's cool
which is cool yeah so the question is is
it gonna be the fulcrum like who's the
fulm like the ful was the fulcrum was a
cool character man he was not gonna do
that in the movie wait
what what are you talking about like
it's an extended scene no he just says
it no at the bar yeah oh he does yeah he
says like I'm the one above all or
something like that I don't know if
that's true or not he could just be
trolling me which would be awesome
congratulations right
like don't don't you or I ever say I am
a God no but the but the the choice of
phrasing is what's unique here like the
one above all a cute throwback I mean I
don't yeah I don't think like the one
above all is gonna show up like I don't
nor do I think that Drax is the one
of yeah it could be he could be he's
merely just observing and pretending
he's just blending in cuz going we're
going to find out that this Drax is the
one above all and then the other Drax
with the cape and the how things going
to show up oh okay well that would be
cool I used to be Arthur
dougas the real one will show up I used
to be Arthur Douglas that guy's the one
above all he could fix all this but you
know what he's got stuff to do so
whatever got stuff to
do s but no um uh that's that's one of
the things I don't like about about the
direction Marvel's going with the whole
Ultimate Universe it seems like Marvel
says well this isn't selling too well so
we'll just throw it over to the Marvel
Universe and the Marvel universe is like
this closet that people just throw their
stuff into and then shut the door and
then
they just keep adding to it the ultim
Universe I thought that was the whole
cataclysm thing like it was over finally
no not no it's it's there I mean you had
you had like ultimatum they just kept
adding stuff to it another another
offshoot about the Cinematic Universe
and it is relevant because it's more
about the comics but isn't it because
characters in the comics are related to
like the X-Men or the Fantastic 4 or
Spider-Man that they they can't be used
at
Marvel so like I I'm just thinking
there's there's got to be some like
loophole in the phrasing of the contract
that Marvel if they put stuff from The
Cinematic Universe into the comics they
can use it well no I know that I know
that Disney owns the Ultimate Universe
because that's what they're playing all
these TV shows off of yeah
yeah so
like the movie the movies are highly
based in the Ultimate Universe but
they're trying to make the
616 basically become the movie Universe
by making it the Ultimate Universe which
isn't selling no but that that's why you
see a lot but it has shorter it has a it
has a smaller has a shorter history and
it's easier to explain so like you know
I me I don't know about easier to
explain but it has a shorter Universe
yeah well
that's to
explain lot going on with new 52
everyone's thinking that they're going
to bring back the original DC Universe
New 52 is going to be their Ultimate
Universe I would pick up I would pick
that up if they did that I I would get
back into DC I didn't realize how much I
missed uh post crisis pre New 52
everything until it was gone I think a
lot of people are like that hopefully DC
editorial is like that they're like man
it was so good back in the day remember
when Grant Morrison was
ruining remember we put grant Morrison
in charge of everything and he made made
it all meta but okay real quick Side
Story because this is funny as crap so
my comic store under ordered
multiversity
2 because they do they do that a lot and
because they didn't know that this was
multiversity
to he thought it was an offshoot so he
didn't order it it looks like it oh wow
you know what's funny actually you're
you're hitting on an interesting point
because that actually is something that
retailers will do um it's why like
Walking Dead 2 is more valuable than
Walking Dead one
the uh they order like you know
retailers order a whole bunch of number
ones but then like after that
speculation dips off they don't order a
whole bunch of number twos which is why
those are actually more rare than number
one sometimes yeah so you'll find that
retailers will actually it doesn't bu
dumb boring never mind anyways Comics
everybody comic books all right Comics
so since we've discussed what's going on
with all new Xmen and everything let's
go to the the last topic we had for
today Rob New York ComicCon yes the
weekly you guys are all going and Rob is
giving away 500 t-shirts that all say
comic that all say comic story on him
comic story is better than Marvel
explain all you need to do is go up to
Rob slap him and be like be like comic
storian like Stan stop making half an
hour long videos 12 minutes is great oh
man but yes yes so we're gonna be at uh
we're gonna be at ComiCon we're getting
there Thursday right Thursday when we go
there for the pre-show um we're all
gonna be filming a bunch of stuff on set
we're gonna do a back issues with sou
forget Ethan and Ben you got us help me
there too but
a I'm actually I'm I'm pretty excited to
meet Ethan and Ben yeah me too I'm
excited for them to meet you guys it's I
thought like you were excited to meet
them I'm like you know them I'm excited
to meet them too it's all
CG actually you don't know them at all
they just show up they're even real
record yeah they're Holograms so what we
wanted to say is that we will be there
we're kind of arranging some kind of a
Meetup time location everything we don't
know what we're going to do um we'll be
walking around with t-shirts I know Rob
and I are making some up to give out if
you can find us um business cards we'll
sign crap whatever you want to do we'll
shake hands um if you stalk us stalk
Dave he he's he wants some stalkers it's
fine true I mean I don't even I don't
really even know if like anybody's gonna
show up to meet us because I don't know
if we're that popular that people oh
we're huge we're huge the entire world
knows who we are let me tell you
something right now we had people at the
TV Little House booth at the Garden
State comicfest people came to our booth
who watched the show people who came
people came to our panel all right elra
monster which is like a third of the
size of comic story and now the original
Channel that I started with um we we
would say we're going to conventions and
people would meet up with us so yeah
it's awesome all right well I mean
little house will have business cards
and we're gonna have like those uh those
postcards which if you watch uh the
newest episode of the newest pre-show of
back issues where we talk about quotes I
want one of those yeah well I'll give
you I'll give you a whole bunch of them
when you get here
okay yeah we'll have those walking
around meeting and greeting we're going
to be talking to people I guess I guess
they're trying to AR you guys are trying
to arrange some kind of like live weekly
poll situation that I'm supposed to
bring equipment for that's a great idea
I mean New York Comic I think we should
do if we do I think we should do um we
should do a like Thursday or a Friday
like wrap up like not a wrap-up episode
but like a Friday Reactions where we
just sit down we do the live stream we
just do we just hit the mics we don't to
do video necessarily but we just hit the
hit the mics and we just do a live thing
where we talk about reactions to the
show what we hope to do next time you
know what do you want to see us do if we
haven't done it yet you know that kind
of thing I mean this is my first
Comic-Con that I'm ever going to so like
yeah I'll be like yeah like if anybody's
coming to ComiCon for the very first
time like if any of you guys watching
this you're going to New York Comic-Con
for the very first time like come see me
because we're going to have so much fun
oh yeah we all are this this is my
second New York ComicCon so I at least
have a little better understanding what
what's going to happen here yeah I'm I'm
so excited to go the uh the New York
ComiCon was the first ComiCon I'd ever
been to In
2005 so this will be my ninth newer
ComicCon do real quick Mr hokii uh I
went to Denver Comic Con this year and
I'm going to drag these three boneheads
to it next year awesome with
that us he needs to drag us to frakin uh
San Diego and San Diego yeah
we've got supposedly tickets being given
to us to go to San Diego that would be
great if we make it to San Diego Comic
Con like that would be so
Beast we're going to New York Des New
York we're going to New York the one
after that will probably be Denver than
San Diego um but we're doing New York
right now we'll be there next year next
month walking around we're getting
t-shirts made up we're hoping they'll be
done in time um like that's that's
tentative because we got to make sure we
can get it done yeah like how long does
it usually cuz I've never had t-shirts
made before get them expedited but if
you can find me my goal is to have at
least at least 10 to give out to the
first 10 people who find me comic storan
much better than the other guys in the
podcast all right sh will say I like
comic story in F the other guys weekly
poll you know what you should do you
just tweet them out and just do hash the
weekly poll and just tweet out I like
and then insert the channel that you
like the most no that's I I I I like
that idea I don't like that idea I like
that idea I don't want I don't want like
you really want to compete with me and
Robson I don't like outright compeition
I'm actually more concerned about
competing with Comics reviews it's just
I know that it's a dark
horse I think I think Rob might actually
kill himself if like if Like Comics
reviews got like an
overwhel we should do that like a PO
like like 90% of give 15,000
subscribers I just want to shake your
hand Dave you're the most amazing guy
ever who's
Rob
like I did actually look some of my
videos are like the second or third
results if I search for like Civil War
like Marvel and in like uh my long
Halloween is like the sixth I think up
on the list for for long Halloween
reviews so like I am slowly getting
there I don't I actually mean to
interrupt you that that
time just every other time every other
time was legit now Mr hooky uh we record
the Grand Slam in Loveland Colorado
every Sunday if you look up Grand Slam
and Loveland you'll find it we go I we
go I go there every Sunday at noon to
record um but yeah so so we'll be we'll
be roaming around there and and hanging
out and chilling and talking to you guys
and like I'll be looking for stuff and
I've I've got I've got something really
planned for all you people out there who
are graphic designers so uh yeah like
I'm I'm pretty psyched for find a local
bar nearby and or Burger Joint that we
can all kind of meet up with after the
show's over that would be cool oh
there's an ass load we no problem it'll
following this Al I was about to give
you the mission of finding a place near
no problem I have I have a couple
friends who actually live there so
that'll be not hard to do oh okay
that'll be good
enough one of two things will happen
everyone will show up we'll have a great
time or no one shows up and we all get
burgers and beer I'm down with that man
that's good enough for me it's a win-win
for
us
what um um I was gonna say what uh as
far as like coverage and video content
is concerned I'm kind of curious to see
what people would want to see us do
slash make yeah tell us what you guys
want to see because I would love to do
like here's something I would love to do
I'd love to do a weekly poll like at
someone's Booth like with anyone who's
going to be there like we could reach
out to any of these creators beforehand
and be like hey man like you want to sit
on sit in with us and do like shorts
like short weekly polls like 15 minute
weekly polls such such and then I've
been bringing up to these guys since the
first of really fully hearing about it
but I have a twitch Channel and I can
stream from my iPad directly to the
twitch channel so if we can arrange for
it we'll be streaming from the show
floor off and on throughout the day on
the twitch channel
so that'll be awesome yeah and then
we'll just take all that and put it
together as one big video at the end the
whole thing but sounds fun to me yeah I
mean I I think no matter what happens
like we're all going to have a blast I
think it's going to be amazing but yeah
we're all flying like I think I'm
getting into new I'm getting into New
Jersey at like
1130 a.m. somewhere around there so if
you want to meet us at the New Jersey
airport yeah yeah if you want to meet us
at New Jersey airport us a LIF to the
con that'd be great we're figure that
that would be pretty awesome if you guys
just give us a lift to Comic-Con that'
be because otherwise we're just going to
catch we don't want to walk Sal's doing
some kind of weird tea train thing that
we don't want to trust yeah I work he's
he's got to be an adult in pay bills I
can't take I can't take two sick days in
a row Thursday and Friday so I'm
like like but I you know but yeah uh but
I you guys have directions now you just
take air train to the air train New New
Jersey Transit new jerse transit station
you we need a limo to pick up Comics
reviews they are he is so big we need a
limo and then me and will just tag along
we'll ride our bikes behind
[Laughter]
him but yeah so um so what do all what
all does everybody have going on this uh
this week this week I'm being
lazy you're playing Destiny you've been
playing Destiny for like the last week
and a half straight all right so I got s
super sick last week I really did get
super sick which was really like okay I
got sick Monday night Tuesday morning I
had Destiny I'm like this is
perfect so I just took the week off and
played Destiny and so this week rolled
around and I'm still playing Destiny and
I'm like okay I need to do Annihilation
which is taking a lot of research in
brightest day which is 25 freaking
issues yep yeah or I can do the three
isue Batman battle for the cow the four
issue original s TI in and play more
Destiny
exactly
yeah I so next week you'll see Brightest
Day in Annihilation probably oh and I'm
also doing Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe cool yeah what you
uh this week uh actually today back
issues did Avengers versus X-men and so
that came out this week uh we also of
course have off the rack Monday through
Wednesday this week we did Death of
Wolverine uh Futures End D Detective
Comics and the Prometheus fire and stone
number one uh which was apparently part
of like a 30 comic Crossover with aliens
and predator and Prometheus and I'm like
oh I just thought it was going to be a
Prometheus
book was kind of cool though yeah it
does but I'm not buying 17 issues at
four or5 a especially not when like the
Art's like so off the rack money through
Wednesday uh back issues on Thursdays
and we had a whole bunch of stuff in
between like we did a a couple of
tangents um we did a uh a criticism
video which uh was fairly
popular um and uh yeah that was funny I
like I I actually enjoyed that thank
you thank you I was like Wow people are
mean to you guys you know what's funny
like I will say and I like number one I
feel really bad because like people like
loyalists were like you know so
apparently all I need to do to get some
attention from the guys over TV little
house is give them a hard time and I'm
like first of all don't do that number
two I'm gonna do that I'm gonna Le
shitty
comments I know who you are like so uh
but what we did like I I had to work
like actually Ethan pitched the idea
he's like I really like that celebrities
read mean tweets bit on uh on Kimmel
yeah and it's such a great bit but he's
like wouldn't it be cool if we did
something like that and I'm like Ethan's
pitching a show idea let's do it so we
uh so we I had to dig deep to find like
eight negative comments and I'm not
saying like stretch yourselves people
and really [__] all over us but I am
saying like we have a really really
awesome community of like really really
positive people yeah and so like that
really blew my mind like I was like I
was actually dipping into comments that
we had already commented on like weeks
or months ago and I'm like oh like I've
run out of negative comments like that's
really cool so while the video seems to
imply that like we are battling the
negativity constantly like it couldn't
be further from the truth on a week by-
week basis so yeah I don't know like
like people leave people leave funny
comments like like people they they'll
phrase it funny though they'll say stuff
like look I don't mean to be rude here
but like your videos [__] suck you
know it's like like like I mean because
do what oh go ahead you go first
somebody asked somebody want me to do um
God who was it somebody wanted me to do
some some obscure character or something
like that and um and they they want like
they they told me like they sent me a
message on on uh YouTube and they were
like I want you to do like if you don't
do this character like like I'm gonna
unsubscribe and I'm like might as well
like what what did you think that like
what do you think was going to happen
like explain to me your thought process
when you sent this message like how you
expect this conversation to go
subcribers I don't understand like s
like like I try to do all the characters
you guys want me to do but the other
thing you remember is there's like
hundreds of thousands of characters in
Marvel
Comics I that same problem I get
requests like all the time do this
obscure story do this obscure character
and then they get mad if I'm like it's
like Annihilation I've been talking
about doing that for a month now but I'm
like do you guys I like I don't know
what people think I do but I actually
sit here with the comic and I actually
take apart the comic put it into a
chunky like size script go through that
script multiple times cleaning it up so
that there's it's these guys have been
on the calls with me when I get stumped
on some of them oh yeah then I take out
every image and put it like this is not
a oh I'm just gonna do this for 30
minutes and then go play Destiny all day
kind of thing this is not a quick
process no but I do I do want to agree
because Rob put out a video about two
weeks ago about this saying you are
awesome and I do want to say the
community that is around our channels
that you guys you really are all awesome
and I will say this from a guy who has
been doing a you for like a year and a
half two years now I have a main channel
that most of you probably don't even
know it's based entirely on video games
and about onethird of those comments are
shitty your voice is horrible I don't
like what you did you left out an
obscure little minute fact that didn't
freaking matter you my favorite is I did
the Metal Gear Solid complete story
videos and someone got upset with me
because I used footage from NES instead
of the MSX they're like you are not a
purist because you didn't use the proper
foot footage in your background I'm like
it doesn't freaking matter the game's
being explained what are you worried
about like and like there's so many
shitty people on YouTube and so many
crappy comments yeah that when I started
this comic book Channel and before I met
Rob and St I expected it to be Tour Part
and just nothing and I was going to
pretty much ignore everything and I
think for the most part same thing with
Rob and S and Dave I don't I almost
never see a shitty comment yeah I
usually never do never never see a
shitty comment and and while I can't
respond to the sheer number of comments
you guys leave on the videos I do read
every single one of them and I know Rob
does and I know s does and I know Dave
does and we really really do appreciate
you guys like you guys are amazing I'm I
agree with Rob's video 100% everyone is
awesome and it's because of you guys
that this is even happening like if this
was just shitty comments in general I
don't think that none of this would have
gone the way it is so yeah it's it's
crazy how like it's it's because of all
the fans I think that this this stuff
has all blown up yeah despite like my
channel starting out out with like a
really crappy webcam and using the
microphone from the webcam and like
saying um like 67 times in my this is
the um I've only got one one dislike on
all of my videos yeah like exactly like
I mean I I don't Rob and I have sat here
and tried to figure it out we don't know
if it's because there's not a lot of
comic channels maybe and we I wasn't
aware of that when I started I thought I
was going to be one of a billion but I
guess Rob knew what he was doing um I
don't know if it's because of the way we
do things between the four of us that we
do that you guys really enjoy it I don't
know what it is but I at least think
every single one of you guys for the
support you're showing for these
channels and us as a group and it's it's
just been incredible for the last couple
of months I'm I'm sorry I'm gushing I'm
just make it easy it's really amazing
yeah awesome I really never expected to
have hundreds of subscribers this
fast like my 10 subcribers I know people
doing YouTube for years years and
they're like I got 200 and Dave's like I
got 200 and I I made a one video like
yeah I I made a video because I went
from 200 to almost 300 so fast that I
was like this could be anywhere from 200
to 300 subscribers by the time Rob Rob
Mak 10,000 celebration videos because of
how fast he's growing yeah oh by the way
guys so apparently I'm I'm approaching
50,000 pretty bad pretty fast so faster
than I thought I would so for 50,000
subscribers we're going to do a live Q&A
like I'm going to live stream like
answering questions that you guys have
great idea so still my idea or the idea
that I stole from sell
yeah I stole it from s you did it worse
I mean yeah but but I want to do like a
live Q&A so you guys can ask me anything
about anything like it's an AMA so you
know ask me anything some stuff I won't
answer some stuff I will it just kind of
depends on the questions you ask like if
you you guys get on there and you ask me
a question like like have you ever
killed flies like I'm probably not going
to answer that question well and I've
for to Rob about this because I did that
and the reason the video is not on there
is I didn't like how it came out because
what it turned into was you guys asking
a question every second and it was just
me being like uh yes I wear pants yes
those are my tattoos um I enjoy that
comic book I don't know what's going on
in Marvel um I don't know what's
happening in that video game uh yeah but
yeah so so for 50k I think a live Q&A
would be pretty fun like I'm pretty ped
about it yeah man so uh so yeah I mean
it's like I'll have it's like right now
it's it's like 7:30 at night and it's
it's like 70 degrees outside so it's too
nice for me to stay inside for the rest
of the night so I'm going to go over to
the guys go hang out with the guys and
watch some football and chill and um the
Hulk versus Iron Man video will be up
tomorrow after that we'll pick up with
original sin and we we only have we have
like five more videos I think before we
finish original sin and then we'll move
on to Infinity Gauntlet because it's
high time we did Infinity Gauntlet my
God I'm so ready to do Infinity Gauntlet
I'm so excited wait wait hold on hold on
hold on you didn't tell me you were
doing Hulk versus Iron Man tomorrow I
would have at least held my release off
well well actually well the reason why
why I did it tomorrow is I was gonna
upload it today and I was like well like
people can just go and and check out
your uh check out your whole thing check
out your video and then I'll do I'll
upload mine tomorrow so it'll give
people chance it'll give people time to
like absorb what you told them because
like like like Benny's covering stuff
that I'm not like I'm covering the
origin story of The Incredible Hulk from
1962 and then what original sin gives us
and then like how that compares to
what's going on in the comics and the
Cinematic Universe but like Benny will
give you guys the relationship between
Bruce Banner and Tony Stark the way the
original sin explains it so that's like
you'll get more information like you'll
get it's kind of a reverse like I'm just
like skimming over a lot of this stuff
really and Benny's getting a little more
in depth yeah like you got you got a lot
more in depth than I did I think but it
was that was a confusing story to tell
like down with that one I sat down with
that one I'm like just real quick before
we close out I sat down with with
original sin Hulk versus Iron Man I'm
playing Destiny I did Batman I'm like I
need to put a video out the other part
of the week I was like i' I've got br's
day started like it's it's I've started
crafting it but it's 20-some issues so
it's taking some time I'm like what can
I do in a hurry oh Hulk versus Iron Man
was four issues and I meant to do it so
let me just knock that out and I sat
there and I read the whole story and
then I looked at it and I went how the
hell am I going to tell this it's in
three different timelines like
yeah it was it
was it was a little nuts like I had to
go back and reread it a couple times and
I'm like all right I don't I mean like
is it right now that he's with the
extremists because yeah exactly like I
thought I've seen that before it's
because it starts with them already
fighting yeah then it jumps back to the
60s then it and then like in the middle
of the 60s there's panels where Bruce
Banner is in the modern day but before
the fight figuring it all out yeah like
it's yeah it was it was a little hectic
I was like oh my God and so finally I
was able to sit down and explain it and
I was like all right this is this is
pretty much how it happens guys but but
I think that's that's the lesson that I
learned with the tians when I was doing
Civil War is the tians are tians because
they explain like an element that
contributes to the story and that's what
I've done like with with the tians with
h Spider-Man and and Hulk versus Iron
Man and I'm debating on even if I want
to do Thor but I'm just sticking to the
aspect of the time Thor's better do Thor
that no Spider-Man okay I'll
do Spiderman watch uh watch my video on
com on TV little yeah it is on comic
story and that's right that's right yeah
it's not even on us it's not why do you
so disappointed about that I'm sorry you
want the video back like you want me to
delete it keep that you have that back
oh but yeah so um but yeah that's that's
what I learned so original sin like the
tiin only cover or the only portion I'm
talking about of the tians are the parts
that like are part of original sin so
but um tians that were really good were
Hulk versus Iron Man and Thor versus
Loki or that's that's what I thought
manant was crap The Avengers was
confusing as all hell and it's not even
really an original sin storyline it's
more of the Illuminati and the new
Avengers plot line than anything yeah
and and somebody wanted me to do X-Men
and I was like no Marvel's just doing
what they can and make X-Men relevant
that's no that's not that's not
happening but um but yeah so uh so what
does uh what do Dave what does Dave have
going on I'm
sorry comic book are you reviewing Dave
well I was kind of taking a break from
from Marvel videos for a while and OB
honestly
like it doesn't take me very long to do
the unpacking videos because literally
what I do is I will open the box on
camera while I'm explaining it and I
will plug my SD card in I will put an
intro and an outro on it and fast
forward through the part where I'm
opening the box and post it like that's
all the editing I do so um you'll get
one of those whenever I get a package
like of comics but um I'm hoping to do
two episodes of Civil War since I've
been taking a break from that yeah and
I'm not going to have very much Marvel
in my packages the next couple months
because I'm getting Indie books and I'm
getting DC books uh for the next couple
months because Marvel's making my head
hurt with with all the stuff I I just
need to I just need to kind of settle
down and let it soak into my brain for a
little while before I read anymore
that's what I was going to say man like
that's the lesson I learned with Civil
War like here's all this
stuff
God yeah so I'm gonna read stuff for a
while and stuff that's easy to read like
you know I just got done with The
Walking Dead compendium One and I just
got done with uh spawn volume one and
Hellboy volume one and and you know some
some a little bit more mellow shorter
like Indie stuff yeah is going to be
good for me for a while that makes
sense totes M goats yeah man all right
well um since s's throwing out weird L
and stuff like that
um um yeah I guess we're going bring
record apparently the sun is the world
is ending for for Rob cuz the lights are
gone like oh yeah yeah I thought like
like earlier it looked like Jesus stand
behind like Jesus was blessing the
podcast was that like dagg stuff I don't
I don't know what it was man like it was
just the light behind me I wasn't trying
to be like shadowy and mysterious
like like they like I was at the crime
scene once and I don't know what
happened we're going to see like Aon
come out of the darkness behind Rob in
the hallway and like take oh yeah that
hallway is creep as crap right now Rob
oh oh is it like a oh God I watched dude
I watched Oculus the other day Okay that
movie scared the hell out of me Robert
you do what are you a big baby oh when
it comes to scary movies you better
believe man I [__] oh dude I I I get
don't watch my Outlast playthrough cuz I
jumped out of my chair doing that
recording Outlast I've heard Outlast is
pretty scary yeah it's just a lot of
jump scenes people just
jump Rob should make a side Channel
where he records himself playing scary
video games no that's not GNA Happ I'm
for that no you should totally do that
before we go though I want to say one
thing all of Rob's viewers you need to
vote Rob's next big video after Infinity
Gauntlet needs to either be madap for
for Deadpool just go ahead and say it or
Superman like S
saiding I am not doing madcap and I'm
not doing Superman
it eventually I will get you to do those
Superman's history is just too massive
so your your excuse for not doing
Superman is just too much Marvel
explained can't explain something oh I
can explain something it's just going to
take too
long besides like super like I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna do a video about a
guy that sings people sings to people
one hour long video mhm apparently Rob
you're a very really lazy Andre the JN
I'm a
lazy like I just don't do I don't do
nothing like I just sit around and choke
slam people in the castle all right I
think that's a good way let's leave it
on that note Rob on
that all right guys uh we will catch you
guys later and and hopefully we'll see
some of you guys at ComicCon so yep and
comic story is the best yeah comic story
is the best anyway we'll catch you guys
later peace see
you